este vídeo es un poquito particular
en esta ocasión queremos responder a
algunas de las cuestiones más
importantes del mundo actual y que al
mismo tiempo más perplejidad no suele
generar a todos porque muchos países
están emitiendo deuda a tipos negativos
porque hay inversores dispuestos a pagar
dinero por financiar a los estados como
esperan los políticos poder financiar
los inmensos planes de gasto público que
están aprobando para enfrentarse al
coronavirus y si te dijese que estas dos
preguntas están muy relacionadas con el
incremento de la desigualdad que se ha
registrado durante las últimas décadas
en los países desarrollados estáis
preparados para adentrarnos en los
entresijos del sistema económico
internacional pues arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la crisis del coronavirus está siendo un
duro castigo para las economías y los
gobiernos de todo el mundo las medidas
tomadas para atajar la crisis sanitaria
como los confinamientos o el cierre de
empresas no sólo han hundido la
actividad económica sino también los
ingresos tributarios al mismo tiempo los
gobiernos están poniendo en marcha todo
tipo de planes de estímulo para tratar
de sortear la crisis es decir están
llevando el gasto público a niveles
desconocidos coronavirus trans firma el
rescate más grande de la historia de los
eeuu alemania anuncia un plan de
estímulo de 130 mil millones mientras el
desempleo crece en europa y japón-
subvencionará el 100% de los salarios de
las pequeñas empresas el programa
ayudará a pagar los salarios completos
de 10 millones de empleados sin ir más
lejos y estoy seguro de que todos
absolutamente todos sabéis de que os
estoy hablando el pasado 21 de julio de
2020 los 27 socios de la unión europea
acordaron un plan de emergencia un plan
de estímulo económico de 750 mil
millones de euros al cambio algo más de
850 mil millones de dólares
[Música]
un plan que implica que por primera vez
la comisión europea emitirá al mercado
ingentes cantidades de deuda para poder
financiarlo es decir a la deuda pública
de los estados miembros ahora se sumará
también a gran escala la de la propia
comisión europea el fondo de
recuperación ha acordado en el consejo
de europa está dotado con 750 mil
millones de euros un auténtico plan
marshall para dar una respuesta
contundente a la crisis del cob y 19
centrarán las transformaciones
necesarias para lograr una economía más
resiliente verde digital inclusiva pedro
sánchez presidente del gobierno de
españa y por supuesto a este plan
comunitario pues hay que sumarle los
planes de estímulos aprobados por cada
uno de los países miembros de forma
individual estamos hablando de una
respuesta de cientos y cientos y cientos
de miles de millones de euros y fuera de
europa el resto de los países del mundo
que están haciendo exactamente lo mismo
y amigos evidentemente sí como
consecuencia de la crisis desatada por
el sars coronavirus 2 los ingresos
públicos caen y los gastos del gobierno
aumentan con que nos encontramos 321
exactamente con enormes déficit públicos
y eso eso es exactamente lo que está
ocurriendo echemos por ejemplo un
vistazo al caso del gran gigante
norteamericano veréis los eeuu
arrancaron el 2020 con una deuda pública
que se situaba ya por encima del 105 por
ciento del pib pero ese dato bueno ese
dato se ha quedado anticuado más rápido
que los bolívares de maduro tras
desatarse la crisis de coronavirus el
congreso de los eeuu aprobó que el mayor
rescate de la historia un rescate de más
de 2,3 billones de dólares amigos el
gobierno federal ha comenzado a quemar
dólares a toda máquina para que os
hagáis una idea tan sólo entre mediados
de abril y mediados de junio la deuda
nacional de los eeuu se incrementó en
más de 2 billones de dólares billones
hispanos 2 millones y un poco más de dos
meses y ojo porque la previsión es que
el gobierno federal cierre el 2020 con
un déficit público de verdad agarrados a
la silla de casi 4 billones de dólares
lo que en términos de pib supone más del
17 por ciento de toda la economía si lo
habéis escuchado bien y no no estamos
hablando de argentina ni de nada por el
estilo sino de los mismísimos eeuu
repito la cifra un déficit público de
más del 10
por ciento déficit presupuestario
federal de los eeuu se acercarán los 4
billones de dólares en 2020 a medida que
la economía continúa en picada e incluso
podría ser peor si las cosas no mejoran
y trump se sale con la suya en el
electoral el presidente está dispuesto a
quemar todas las balas para ser
reelegidos
[Música]
de esta forma amigos a eeuu cerrará el
2020 con una duda pública aproxima al
130 por ciento del pib más de 28
millones de dólares para que os hagáis
una idea dos veces el tamaño de toda la
economía china siete veces la economía
alemana o veinte veces la economía
española y eso eso es lo que explica
noticias como ésta eeuu alcanzará
niveles de deuda pública similares a los
de japón para el 2050 y la pregunta que
podemos hacer no sé cómo demonios
piensan financiar los gobiernos todo
este gigantesco torrente de deuda
pública billones y millones de dólares
de más y más y más deuda pública pues
aquí amigos aquí es donde aparece en
acción una de las instituciones más
importantes del tejido económico mundial
los bancos centrales queréis un ejemplo
del papel que juegan este tipo de
instituciones pues fijaos
[Música]
de los meses de marzo y abril el
departamento del tesoro de los eeuu
emitieron 156 millones en títulos de
deuda del 'tío sam' y la pregunta es
sabéis cuánta deuda del gobierno de los
eeuu compró la fed la reserva federal
durante ese mismo tiempo pues ni más ni
menos que un billón y medio de dólares
es decir durante los meses de marzo y
abril la reserva federal compró el
equivalente a toda la deuda emitida por
el gobierno de los eeuu no lo hizo
directamente es verdad fueron compras de
deuda que ya había sido emitida pero en
última instancia el resultado no es
diferente la reserva federal crea una
demanda artificial sobre la deuda
pública lo que mantiene reducidos los
precios y los tipos de interés de los
bonos de deuda emitidos por el gobierno
además de garantizar la liquidez del
mercado
[Música]
si lo habéis escuchado bien la fe te
está respaldando la deuda emitida por el
gobierno de los eeuu a unos niveles muy
elevados nunca antes visto y la pregunta
que aquí seguramente muchos os hagáis es
y con qué está pagando la reserva
federal la compra de toda esta enorme
cantidad de deuda del gobierno
norteamericano
[Música]
pues amigos estoy seguro que los que nos
20 argentinas conocéis el proceso
perfectamente con dinero nuevo con
dinero creado de la nada y si otra vez
no habéis escuchado a la perfección la
reserva federal- exactamente igual que
el resto de los bancos centrales crean
dinero de la nada es lo que se conoce
como darle una y otra y otra vez a la
máquina de imprimir billetes claro que
en realidad es mucho más fácil basta con
teclear unos cuantos números en un
ordenador para crear dinero nuevo dinero
nuevo con el que luego hacen operaciones
como comprar la deuda de los gobiernos
un momento mono porque los bancos
centrales están creando dinero nuevo
para comprar la deuda pública así por
arte de magia pues si eso es exactamente
lo que está ocurriendo ahora bien que
están haciendo exactamente qué
consecuencias pueden tener este tipo de
procesos hasta donde alcanzan sus
operaciones pues amigos lo vamos a ver
en este vídeo pero antes antes tenemos
que saber exactamente quiénes son y cómo
juegan los bancos centrales atentos
el corazón del sistema financiero
exactamente que es un banco central sí
lo sé por lo general son entidades
totalmente desconocidas para el gran
público pero sin embargo a la hora de la
verdad su implicación sobre nuestras
vidas puede llegar a ser enorme los
bancos centrales son las entidades que
gestionan la producción y distribución
del dinero que controla la masa
monetaria y el nivel de tipos de interés
son el punto neurálgico el corazón del
sistema financiero moderno claro que
hablamos de un tipo de bancos muy
especiales entre otras cosas porque no
interactúan con el público digamos que
sus clientes son básicamente los bancos
comerciales
su principal objetivo suele ser mantener
la estabilidad de los precios y en
algunos casos también apoyar la creación
de empleos y la actividad económica
amigos los bancos centrales se han
convertido en entidades tan importantes
para el sistema financiero moderno que
cada vez que se produce una situación de
crisis suelen ser la primera línea de
defensa a la que recurren los políticos
de todo el mundo y la pregunta es para
qué es lo que hacen
pues veréis tradicionalmente los bancos
centrales recurren a estrategias como
modificar el nivel de tipos de interés
inyectar nuevo dinero a la economía o
apoyar a los bancos que tengan problemas
de liquidez es por eso por lo que
también se les conoce como prestamistas
de última instancia de hecho estoy
completamente seguro pero seguro seguro
de que todos absolutamente todos sin que
importe en lugar del que nos estáis
viendo habéis escuchado un montón de
veces cosas como que el banco central
baja los tipos de interés para estimular
la inversión y así hacer crecer la
economía
cuando las empresas pueden financiarse a
tipos de interés más bajos entonces
tienden a invertir más lo que a su vez
genera más actividad económica y más
empleos por supuesto como veremos esto
tiene otras muchas implicaciones porque
el tipo de interés en la práctica se
reduce inyectando nuevo dinero lo que a
su vez puede erosionar el valor del
dinero existente es decir puede crear
inflación y muchos otros problemas
económicos
[Música]
y el caso es que esta fue la estrategia
básica que siguieron hasta la última
gran crisis la crisis financiera del
2008 y en ese momento los bancos
centrales de prácticamente todos los
países desarrollados del planeta
redujeron los tipos de interés hasta el
nivel de cero
[Música]
[Aplausos]
esto es por ejemplo lo que hizo como
podéis ver en este gráfico la reserva
federal- que por otra parte es algo muy
similar a lo que ya hizo en su día el
banco central de japón
[Música]
y la pregunta es y qué ocurre cuando los
tipos ya están por los suelos a niveles
cercanos a cero que pueden hacer
entonces los bancos centrales ojo que no
es una pregunta cualquiera todo lo que
está ocurriendo hoy en día a nivel de
rescates y política económica tiene
precisamente mucho que ver con esta
pregunta pero vale me explico por
ejemplo cuando estalló la crisis de el
coronavirus los bancos centrales lo
primero que hicieron fue lo de siempre
bajar los tipos de interés pero claro
bajar otro 0 5 al 0 por ciento pues no
supone mucho cambio no es como cuando se
reducían del 6 al 3 por ciento por
ejemplo la capacidad de respuesta en
este sentido es cada vez más limitada
pero por supuesto esto no significa que
vayan a quedarse de brazos cruzados para
nada este problema se puso ya sobre la
mesa a partir del 2008 y fue entonces
cuando los bancos centrales presentaron
la conocida como política monetaria no
convencional también llamada en pomposo
lenguaje tecnócrata expansiones
cuantitativas y en qué consiste en este
tipo de estrategias políticas pues
básicamente darle una y otra y otra vez
a la máquina de imprimir billetes una y
otra y otra vez lo que como ya os he
dicho en términos modernos equivale a
[ __ ] un teclado y empezar a pulsar
compulsivamente las teclas de números
para crear más y más dinero nuevo y
amigos como solemos decir por aquí dicho
y hecho
[Música]
fijaos por ejemplo como la reserva
federal de los eeuu incrementó la
cantidad de dinero de circulación a
partir del 2008 y la pregunta que
podemos hacernos es qué demonios hacen
con todo este nuevo dinero pues amigos
simple y llanamente lanzarlo sobre el
mercado comprando todo tipo de activos
hipotecas bonos bancarios y
fundamentalmente deuda en circulación de
los gobiernos es decir como ya hemos
dicho se la compran a otros inversores y
no a los propios gobiernos porque
formalmente salvo que seas un país como
venezuela que está prohibido monetizar
deuda es decir para entendernos que los
bancos centrales no pueden financiar
directamente a los gobiernos aunque
luego la práctica lo que viene hacer sea
muy similar
la idea con estas expansiones
cuantitativas es inundar los mercados de
liquidez crear una demanda artificial y
lograr que de esta forma se reduzcan los
costes de financiación para gobiernos
bancos y empresas por ejemplo de esta
forma en poco más de seis años entre el
2008 y el 2015 el balance de la reserva
federal se multiplicó casi por 5 pasando
de 1 a más de 4 billones y medio de
dólares es decir en poco más de 6 años
la reserva federal creó más de 3
millones billones hispanos de nuevos
dólares para intervenir en los mercados
financieros y adulterar los costes de
financiación en especial el coste de
financiación del gobierno de los eeuu no
sólo fue cosa de eeuu el banco central
europeo el banco central de japón o el
banco de inglaterra entre otros muchos
hicieron lo mismo
pero eso eso no fue nada comparado con
la respuesta que ahora han dado a la
crisis de coronavirus amigos puede que
no lo sepáis pero en 2020 estamos
presenciando un histórico experimento
monetario la mayor expansión
cuantitativa de toda la historia y ojo
porque este experimento no está exento
de riesgos quieres saber a qué nos
enfrentamos pues atentos
[Música]
corona recesión llega a la caballería
pesada amigos amigas en esta ocasión los
bancos centrales han decidido dar todo
un puntazo en la mesa y como hemos visto
ya intervinieron decididamente en la
anterior crisis ahora en 2020 han decido
pasar a una dimensión superior fijaos
por ejemplo como reaccionado en la
reserva federal presta atención tan sólo
entre los meses de marzo abril mayo y
junio la reserva federal ha creado
dinero y ha ampliado su balance en casi
tres billones de dólares para que os
hagáis una idea esto es más que el
tamaño de toda la economía de la india
el reino unido francia es una cantidad
tan grande de dinero que con ella la
reserva federal podría haberse comprado
por ejemplo prácticamente todas las
empresas cotizadas en las bolsas de
londres y milán o por ejemplo todas las
alemania españa y brasil juntas
y qué están haciendo con semejante
cantidad del dinero pues comprando de
todo deuda del gobierno federal de euro
de los estados de los municipios de los
bancos hipotecas e incluso deuda
corporativa de grandes empresas privadas
[Música]
y no solo se trata de la reserva
federal- si tenemos en cuenta los bancos
centrales de eeuu europa canadá reino
unido japón y australia la previsión es
que esperan incrementar sus balances
como mínimo en más de 9 billones de
dólares durante el 2020 y si no mejoran
las cosas al final podría ser mucho
muchísimo más dinero
[Música]
y amigos ya lo tenemos así es
exactamente como los políticos de todo
el mundo esperan financiar sus
gigantescos programas de rescate y
estímulo económico
básicamente confían en que los bancos
centrales creen tanto dinero nuevo como
para estimular artificialmente la
demanda de deuda lo suficiente como para
que ellos puedan financiar todos sus
inmensos planes de gasto público por
ejemplo se espera que para finales de
este 2009 el banco central europeo- si
el propietario ojo de más del 30 por
ciento de toda la deuda pública emitida
por los países que forman la eurozona
más del 30 por ciento es decir el
principal acreedor de los países de la
eurozona pues es el propio banco central
europeo así que en otras palabras los
bancos centrales se han convertido en la
herramienta que hace posible todos los
incrementos de gasto público pero unam
en todo momento esto creamos dinero
nuevo y ya está tan fáciles pues
evidentemente no
[Música]
emitir más y más dinero tiene
consecuencias quienes nos estáis viendo
desde países como argentina o venezuela
lo sabéis perfectamente este tipo de
políticas erosionar el valor del dinero
y causan problemas como inflación
inestabilidad financiera y burbujas de
todo tipo y ojo porque puede que nunca
te lo hayan contado pero también pueden
causar una mayor desigualdad pero aquí
aquí puede que alguno esté pensando pero
enrique inflación de verdad venga ya si
está bajo mínimos pues sí y no depende
de por donde miremos por ejemplo durante
las últimas décadas las grandes
innovaciones tecnológicas y la
globalización con la entrada en el
comercio mundial de países como china
han propiciado un gran incremento de la
productividad y la eficiencia con ello
los precios podrían haberse desplomado y
sin embargo pues no lo han hecho verdad
es decir ha existido una inflación
camuflada por el efecto de las mejoras
en la producción
pero no solo eso qué ocurre si
comparamos la evolución de los precios
inmobiliarios o la evolución de las
bolsas y demás activos patrimoniales con
respecto a los salarios por ejemplo que
en todos los casos se han disparado y
eso es además de explicarnos porque cada
vez es más difícil acceder por ejemplo
una vivienda también nos cuenta porque
en los países ricos está creciendo la
desigualdad entre los más ricos y los
más pobres si me habéis escuchado bien
la política monetaria tiene mucho que
ver con que la desigualdad haya crecido
en los países más ricos durante las
últimas dos décadas y es que veréis
junto a todo este efecto de inflación en
los activos patrimoniales que
evidentemente beneficia a quienes más
patrimonios netos tienen se produce
también otro fenómeno el conocido como
efecto cantillon fijaos
puede resultar confuso pero la creación
de nuevo dinero favorece
fundamentalmente a los primeros en
recibirlo es decir a los primeros que
logran financiarse con este nuevo dinero
creado de la nada a los primeros en ser
regados con el dinero del banco central
porque pues porque son los primeros en
poder operar con el nuevo dinero sin que
éste haya impactado todavía en los
precios ya sea de bienes de consumo o
bienes de inversión y quienes son los
primeros en acceder a este recurso pues
fundamentalmente gobiernos bancos y
grandes empresas y esto también es lo
que explica que los gobiernos cada vez
sean más grandes y que las pequeñas y
medianas empresas lo tengan cada vez más
difícil y aún más cuando el banco
central europeo- la fed compran bonos de
deuda de empresas como por ejemplo no sé
telefónica y logran que ésta pueda
financiarse a tipos ridículamente
reducidos a pesar de estar muy endeudada
lo que hacen es favorecer la frente
otras empresas más pequeñas que tienen
que pagar mucho más por la financiación
[Música]
así que si sumamos estos tres efectos
que hemos visto lo que tenemos es que
este tipo de políticas monetarias no
sólo conllevan el riesgo de crear nuevas
burbujas y alimentar el gasto público
sino que también también hacen crecer la
desigualdad entre los más ricos y los
más pobres
sorprendidos amigos la crisis de
coronavirus probablemente requiera de
acciones contundentes pero no estaremos
confiando en exceso en la capacidad de
los bancos centrales son los incentivos
de los que toman las decisiones es decir
los políticos los mismos que los
nuestros o miran quizás más al corto
plazo a las próximas elecciones
realmente estamos preparados para
afrontar las consecuencias de todas
estas políticas no estaremos acaso
corriendo el peligro de no se japón izar
nuestras economías volvernos adictos a
las deudas hipertrofiar nuestros estados
o dañar el valor de nuestras monedas
emisor política estaremos atentos a cómo
discurrir los acontecimientos pero como
siempre decimos nuestras son las
preguntas y vuestras las respuestas así
que dejarnos nuestras opiniones por aquí
abajo en los comentarios y ya sabéis si
este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle al botón de like
suscribiros abisal político una vez más
muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]